[Music]
I am half Dalek and for the past three
years I've been working with the
strategic reforms unit at the punjab
Chief Minister's office in Pakistan on
violence against women and women
empowerment reforms the existing case
for process to give justice to these
victims is so fragmented and
disconnected the victim first has to go
to a police station to register a crime
then a medical treatment facility to get
lake first a treatment or a medical
examination conducted a medical
examination it has to be collected
within 48 hours so that the evidence can
actually be used in the court to prove
that the violence has been taking place
as endured they don't have access to
these medical facilities and because
they don't have there's no proof that
the crime actually took place
then there's forensics then the
prosecution then courts and so forth so
the victims will to actually go ahead
and prosecute crime the decreases
tremendously because of this fragmented
cash flow process I mean back in those
days this is a summer of 2014 we were
hearing reports of how female victims
were dousing themselves were dousing oil
petrol on themselves and then setting
themselves on fire in front of police
stations just to gain attention from
media and other stakeholders to get
their voices heard to get their cases
registered in the police station in the
first place that our own investigation
indicates in getting the cooperator
justice but just getting a first
information report police report existed
and in that got us thinking how what can
we do to facilitate the victims as much
as possible to provide them to provide
them a comprehensive justice delivery
system and and then there was back then
that we started having discussions on
our commitment violence against women
centre and what it should look like back
in the summer of 2014
this was just an idea on providing all
the victims justice delivery services
under one roof to stream and the case er
process to make sure that they're
getting justice and then by providing
them justice in increasing the
conviction rate creating a deterrence
into society
prevent such crimes in the first place
and in since 2015 working on it since
2014 and and we launched our pilot
violence against women Center on March
25th 2017 and and we received more than
thousand victims in these last six
months and we've been providing them all
sorts of services and we've actually
successfully resolved it more than 800
of these cases that just shows the need
for such centers and reforms to be in
Anakin's of society or in society or
like Pakistan or in regions like
Pakistan where there is high prevalent
prevalence of gender-based violence
crimes and there needs to been there's
important they need to have a
comprehensive strategic solution to
address those issues while we were in
consultation delegations at how to make
the reform or enhance if we also decided
to give the centers on legislative cover
and and that's when we started drafting
the punjab protection of women against
violence act 2016 now this act is the
first of its kind in in Pakistan because
it provides civil remedies to the
victims and it's not just provision of
civil remedies suppose I'll talk about
in a bit but also having an
implementation mechanism are to make
sure that these remedies are enforced so
when we were researching in in human in
any you would have seen this time when I
mean again in the union's as well that
the Pakistan government or various
provincial governments are coming up
with various various reforms to address
violence against women to have them in
empowerment reforms and you had these
empowerment initiatives coming from
civil society as well
but the issue is that all of these
reforms are relying on the existing
structure to get them implemented the
existing system which we've seen that
isn't that it is not delivering justice
and it is not providing justice to the
victims to have innovative reforms
implemented properly you need to have a
completely different system which is in
line with the vision
with which the reform was thought of and
also so for every innovative reform you
need to have a specific mindset to
implement them and to implement this
legislation into the monthly centers we
needed to have a completely new system
which was staffed with human resource
individuals who were sensitized towards
this issue and who wanted to bring a
change and we personally interviewed
more than 600 candidates and in our sole
criteria was borrowing the expertise
that were involved in the respective
fields but also how sensitized their
world was an issue even if the victim
was was sexually assaulted by her
boyfriend sheesh by her husband or by
her boyfriend she she is a victim here
and needs to be dealt with properly
professionally and the sensitized manner
so that was our first first and foremost
criteria how sensitized they were
towards the issue
so coming coming back and talking about
the implementation mechanism again so
we've seen that all these existing
structures have failed to provide
justice because their mindset is not
aligned with the vision or with the
progress the vision to make sure that
the the new innovative reforms are
implemented and victims are provided
justice so then then the hair that's
where walk comes in the picture it's the
most comprehensive system that's been
designed and implemented in fact with
South Asia's first of its kind Center
that's been designed and implemented and
its sole task is to provide to
streamline the whole case her process to
provide justice to victims survivors of
gender-based violence but also provide
them with post trauma rehabilitation and
then assimilate them into society
and basically make them independent
[Music]